storytime zu Ramadan Tag 2 und wie wir
heute zum Iftar in einer fremden Wohnung
gelandet sind heute sollten wir das
Fasten in der Gemeinschaft brechen das
heißt auswärts wir sind also zur Adresse
gegangen haben aber dabei nicht gemerkt
dass wir aus Versehen im Nachbarhaus
waren schon im Flur kamen uns junge
Menschen entgegen die gesagt haben ja ja
ihr seid hier richtig kommt rein also
dann gemerkt haben dass da niemand ist
den wir kennen ist uns klar geworden
dass wir falsch sind lustigerweise haben
uns diese Menschen aber gar nicht als
fremd angesehen und wir hätten auf jeden
Fall auch mit den dort essen können das
zeigt einfach dass die Religion ein doch
zueinander führt und wie wichtig
Gastfreundschaft ist am Ende des Tages
sind wir dann aber doch zur richtigen
Adresse gegangen